let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we are going to start with our
caller from the 703 area code 703 go
ahead hey David hey who's this go ahead
jack what's on your mind about this new
Amazon $15 minimum wage increase thing
going on because uh I saw that Bernie
kind of gave Bezos in Amazon in general
a lot of trees for raising the minimum
wage there but I actually I think in
this situation the rhetoric kind of
needs to be a little bit different and
that I think needs be careful giving
praise today in this just because I
don't think that is in tension you know
regardless of whether it has the right
policy you know it is only one company
right he's really only doing it I think
for you know to save space and I think
by doing too much great to be as us
these kind of set himself up for
something you know down the line and I
saw the video that you had a channel
that other gentleman who was thrown in
for you and us about it um and I just
think I mean takeaways if you know we're
already seeing that of course what
leaders had to do and what Amazon had to
do is they had to go and cut you know
some of the other benefits in order to
account for this wage increase had to a
choice Jack I think a key question is
they had to or they chose to because
they didn't really have to you could
take a little bit of it you know out of
out of the executives and you don't have
to but they chose to I think is the key
course you know corporations
interviewers they're going to try to
maximize their profits at any cost and
so in order to adjust that wage increase
of course the first thing you did is to
cut the other benefits so I think doing
too much credit to business and Amazon
is heading Bernie up so I you know I
don't think his intentions are bad I do
think that other people might portray it
as you know kind of short-sighted yeah
listen
this is similar to with the universal
basic income okay which is it deserves
the praise that it deserves and not more
than that if it was more common that
there was a $15 minimum wage at small
businesses and also at these massive
corporations there wouldn't be a PR
benefit to Amazon announcing we are now
going to pay $15 an hour because that
would just be what everybody pays and
there's no PR value to it whatsoever so
it's the initial correct decision which
you accurately point out it deserves
credit in saying Amazon is choosing to
do this but they don't have to do it
right now but why are they doing it it's
not just or exclusively for the welfare
of the employees it's because right now
because it's so uncommon there's a PR
benefit to it and of course on the
backend they're gonna save money
elsewhere you're insane you know with
universal basic income there's a lot of
these tech billionaires who say we need
universal basic income is it the right
policy I think it is but you also have
to consider that when the average person
gets some additional basic income a lot
of that money is going to be spent back
on Amazon where people get a lot of
their stuff their day-to-day stuff on
Amazon Prime 100 million ppm bruh
households or however many are members
so just because something might be
self-serving doesn't mean it's not the
right policy but just because it's right
the right policy we shouldn't ignore the
fact that there's a context in which
these decisions are being made which
could be for self-serving reasons as
well
right absolutely I'm pretty much agree
to everything and just to add real quick
yeah I also feel like this could
actually set up the Republicans to do a
cynical play here where they can say oh
look we raise the you know the $15 you
know we raised that for them but look
look what happened in as a result they
will they lose these benefits and
somehow I could see them trying to spin
that into a look this is the fault of of
the wage increase and not of you know
Amazon doing whatever they can to make
sure that they make up for that on that
you know hit to their their bottom line
yeah they will do that I'm right right
absolutely they absolutely will do that
jack thank you so much for the call
really appreciate it great to hear from
you